hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to per idiom now this is a
pixelated point-and-click adventure game
it's really highly rated on gamejolt and
it was originally made in a game jam and
then polished up for later release and
it takes place in the frozen wastelands
of some taken lon first though we didn't
know it then didn't understand that did
look in her eyes that unnatural wouldn't
lurching motionless she moved about the
lab course was too late when I learned
to read the signs most of the crew were
in it spell already and I paid a
terrible price for my blindness was
either last I could hear their footsteps
on the snow outside my cabin letting the
steps moving as one not safe here
I'll make for the lab that was damn good
voice acting hello buddy
pain throbbing from the gaping hole in
my stomach yeah of course
that could have gone better you're a
grizzle there's all hell oh hey I'd
rather not swimming
I almost black out again come on Jim
there's nothing to worry about
[Music]
watch your language or whatever it is
that's living in his body now
there's a little concernings Heath
against another wave of agony keep it
together
okay let's try to be baddest gotta get
these bleeding under control okay
you can't Harris you're doing good out
there but I gotta look work fast need
something to laver it okay yeah but I
bet I got a hurry because I wanna drag
rattled around in the toolbox can I have
that you just said that there was a
rusty rare rhombus on the ancient funky
buried deep beneath the ice would have
been the culmination of a decade of
research the better part of our lives
together
I know it never finished now but perhaps
I can pass on the torch maybe I guess
that's one way to look at your imminent
demise oh hi Wilkins how are you doing
okay Wilkins what you got for me
kneeling down over the body
I noticed the tell-tale in him and the
signs on his face he was also wearing
one of those armbands I've noticed on
the others well god the stench coming
off him was losing consciousness again
but desperate not persist cool I find
the key in his jeans pocket I like that
this guy's like me I narrate my own life
in third person when I'm in crisis at
the radio my heart sinks a stray bullet
it's smashed right through it oh [ __ ] I
said damn not [ __ ] watch your language
she's running fine alright fine then a
cabinet maybe medical supplies in there
long why found a small blowtorch okay
good there's nothing else use nothing to
mess with that found some main looking
wire cutters me
bad boys I'm all about some me no bad
boys wire counter breach I'm too short
god damn it this game new my one
weakness thinking to move the barrel
closer to the wiring I give it a push
that's exactly what I was my stomach is
indescribable well there tries myself up
first try to describe it to me say it's
so soothingly smooth no he's opening it
nothing human out there for a thousand
guys what's a cave
come on Chima open the door I promise
everything will be okay mate all right
that accent good luck watch your mouth
if you have one and listening to that
thing out there excuse you who the [ __ ]
was that
it's gotta be a way to patch me up
Beauty radio is useless to me broken and
I can't fix it with my bare hands all
right but then why did it go through
clear to go near the thing again
yeah thing so is this about the movie
the face no girls the only thing keeping
us from a quick and icy death
refrigerated cabinet wholesome anti we
keep a small supply of morphine on the
base to
huh can I open this there's got to be a
we're gonna plant there's got to be
something else I can do around here do I
haven't oh I do okay I've been inventory
so I got all this [ __ ]
keep that yes that's what I got to do
clicks open give me that morphine baby
with hungrily possible for here
antibiotics get it in bandages put it at
my gaping hole during lab samples in
here again strictly forbidden but the
lab fridge had been on the fritz for
weeks the sample caught my eye
thin scarlet membrane stretched over a
pulsating bulbous growth pulsating away
a cloud of crews and spores eyes
nostrils throat burning my cough and the
action triggers a dagger of pain from my
wound still I managed not to blackout in
at least the cabinet's open have I been
infected have I been affected only
slowed my mind so clenching my teeth to
suppress screams of agony i injected
some penicillin around the world before
bandaging it up I'm infected now I am I
nod I'm very in fact
[Music]
if there was a way to avoid that I bet
there was but I don't know can't reach
reach get on the goddamn oh yeah guess
I'm on the girl you're happy to cut the
wire
I feel something brushed against my mind
Oh vast and terrible that me fleeting
whisper of contact a freight train
roaring through my consciousness I was
drowning okay from deep beneath my mind
I could feel that force animating my
limbs like a monstrous puppeteer lungs
burning I struggled to the surface
[Applause]
[Music]
it's fine
Oh God Oh God research all geez I don't
know Oh God
was that what the others had felt okay
I've got to get help
yeah I don't think there's any help for
you I didn't even know what I was
supposed to be doing there all right
well I got wire so what good is that
gonna do me Oh
despite the tremor in my fingers of
managed to undo the screws yay radios
useless to me bro okay why are in it I
have these fused wiring foot okay all
right positioning away the fused wiring
did it have a vision collecting fusiform
stem samples with my wife laughter let's
see ah she'll be working now okay sure
grab the receiver dr. James Turner from
station theta 6 6 1 do you copy
the welcome sound of a friendly voice
comes through the static oh thank god
I need evac ASAP this mean something
horrible has happened
yep tell the crew do not land until they
see repeat to not land until they see
dr. Parker
kopi over and out okay I don't know if
they're gonna follow those instructions
go for that all right cool
well that is a thing that happened now
what do we do wavering on my feet
exhausted a sink to the floor to wait
that seems like a bad idea
fools like a lid good I wouldn't do that
if I were you I would stay awake
[Music]
like nothing very wrong cold my mind my
body stiff and numb the pain like hot
LED being poured over my hands my feet
my face okay I struggle to move my limbs
tearing yourself away from the frozen
floor oh it's cold
okay ah the furnace is no good this you
Lynette but she's a tricky thing to get
started they defined some kindling and
something delighted with okay right or
else what I'm gonna die
I got a haha oh I've got my research
oh no tearing up a decade of work Oh
throw it in Oh stand close to feeling
turns to my face that's bad well there
goes all that stuff but I'm alive you
listen what's the point of being alive
you're re and attracted right okay what
do I do about whatever I need to do I
still need to get this locker open I
never got the locker Open it's quiet out
there
time to go I don't believe it
when I hear shouts and body-slamming to
the other side myself at the door but
too late
they were like arms twisting their way
in how long I can hold it take a good
church to put it away myself Lord strong
light but it flares to life and I hold
it against the arm wielding that knife
let's drop it again there's the smell of
burning hair and pork crackling feels
lost wrestling screams from outside and
the knife clatters on the floor lunge
for the lunge baby in one go steel I
shut my eyes and start hacking the
muffled screams from behind the door the
sticky works splashing on my arms
finally I'll feel the door slam closed
behind my back okay oh good I have an
arm like a pale worm I get done well
maybe it's a good lever the same band
they all did once they turned another
one of those [ __ ] arm bands getting a
full box of cartridges inside oh it's
loaded and I'm ready as I'll ever be
okay
alright so I got the window or the door
again I'll leave it alone
what guy could shoot from the window
fine alright this seems this doesn't
seem wise but alright you know what
what's going results from my Latin let's
go for it
weapons shaking in my hand I swung the
heavy door open yeah sure this is gonna
Gregory
Jim put it down
look Ben's here no dad it's me I'm
coming in Oh No
mom called before she I just got in it
knows Ben get out of here run dad put
the gun down but they killed Kathy Ben
dad it was an accident they they told me
what look it wasn't your fault
what are you doing can't fight it much
longer
hey you need help please I can't think
but if they matter
what
oh no oh no every synapse a mine fitted
mind aids you need to pull the trigger
[Music]
oh god babe
wrongness is in his face and
what's that what it's nothing what are
you doing
drop the gun I can't let it hit him too
no their son
was it the right call
oh you're not gonna tell me oh you're
not gonna tell me are you oh it's a
mystery I was infected was I the only
one who was infected but they all fine
why did harvest wanna get him so bad oh
man Oh No
Oh No hey crew the new radiation monitor
bands arrived this morning
[Music]
[Applause]
it made me kill my own son but that was
with the arms the arms make no sense if
like nothing was bad then the arms they
wouldn't have just they wouldn't have
been so desperately trying to get in
something was wrong wasn't it I don't
think you know hole in my god
[Music]
what if they have to what
[Music]
pants shaking
[Music]
what am I just wait and I stay home
yeah maybe maybe could have been
anything wrong I'm so tired
[Music]
it's got nothing's happening I better
here for a while
[Music]
and exhausted
I'll let it take me
and that's not gonna oh it's no matter
what you do see it doesn't were they
infected or not everything points to
this like actually being a thing cuz one
why did they come in all arms in with a
knife they came in with a knife I mean
everyone had the armbands obviously for
the radiation oh what the [ __ ]
take him for processing
ah okay all right so it makes you feel
bad it makes you feel bad no matter what
you choose oh okay all right okay all
right okay all right take him for
processing oh yeah sure okay all right
so I want to know more about this this
was really cool I love the way that it
played out I'm point click the the
narration though the voice actor was
really good on that one so it made it
really interesting so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought of it down in the
comments below hopefully there's more of
this in the future so thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]